how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about the thing
that we all love Marvel and today we're
going to be talking about Adam warlock
making his way to the MCU this is
something that fans have been waiting
for for a very long time since he was
teased at the end of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 in the post-credits scene
now since he appeared in that
post-credit scene in guardians 2
everybody is expecting him to make his
MCU debut in guardians of the galaxy vol
3 especially since James Gunn director
of guardians 1 & 2 is still going to be
directing guardians 3 however James Gunn
is pretty much an open book when it
comes to certain things about guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 he's done many q and
A's on Instagram and he's answered a lot
of questions on Twitter as well and we
really haven't gotten that much
information from him about Adam warlock
but today we do have a report from Mikey
Sutton about Adam warlocks future in the
MCU and it may not be what you're
expecting so I'll break it down in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up-to-date on all the
MCU content and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win an
Ironman Funko pop so we'll start off by
reading this report straight from Mikey
Sutton he says he was supposed to be
perfect but in the MCU Adam warlock will
be a figure he was the epitome of
physical beauty on the outside but
flawed on the inside rumored but also
teased to debut in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 Marvel Studios has been
wanting to introduce him which is
actually Adam warlocks original name him
for quite a while there simply wasn't
enough space and time in infinity war
which was his logical entrance based on
the comic book continuity Adam warlocks
MCU debut and entrance is shrouded in
mystery however his destination has
leaked Marvel Studios is seeking to drop
annihilation on their millions of fans
with warlock as among its primary leads
this will not be his first appearance
rather it's where he is headed in this
proposed epic warlock will collaborate
with other cosmic superheroes including
quasar moon dragon and Captain Marvel
against Annihilus Galactus and Terrax
the tamer the project is in the earliest
stages of discussion so it remains to be
seen how closely it will echo its comics
predecessor and according to inside
sources this might not be an Avengers
movie but simply focus on the MCU star
hop
characters however War Luck will play a
huge role in this movie one that was
recently denied and there's somebody
else who was scheduled to appear in
annihilation and you can head over to
the YouTube channel Lords of the Lum box
to hear the second part of the scoop but
let's break this down for just one
second this is the future that Marvel is
heading towards Kevin Feige has already
confirmed this multiple times that the
future of the MCU is a cosmic future we
know that the MCU is actually going to
be divided there's going to be a ground
team consisting of the superheroes that
are on earth taking care of earthly
threats and then there's going to be a
cosmic team a team that exists in space
and is dealing with otherworldly threats
Captain Marvel of course said to be one
of them leading the future of the cosmic
team Thor if he still has a future in
the MCU after Thor love and thunder and
now it seems like they're going to be
bringing an Adam warlock to join that
group as well taking on a leadership
role and will eventually go on to take
on the one and only Galactus Galactus is
said to be the big bad of the MCU even
though we most likely won't see him
until five to six years later where they
start to tease him but by that time
warlock should have made his MCU debut
hopefully in guardians of the galaxy vol
3 since he was set up in vol 2 as Mikey
said his entrance is shrouded in mystery
however it looks like he has a very
bright and long future in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so let me know what
you think about this epic news of Adam
warlocks feature in the MCU and again
head over to Lords of the long box for
the second part of the scoop be sure to
give the video a like and subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and of course for
live updates you can follow me on
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof